the Joe Rogan experience I've often
wondered if what we think of when in
terms of like artificial life from
another plant or life or another planet
is that it's like an artificial creation
like in our ideas that we understand
that the biological limitations of the
body when it comes to traveling through
space the dealing with radiation death
need for food things along those lines
that what we would do is create some
artificial thing to travel for us like
we've already done on Mars right we have
a rover that roams around Mars the next
step would be an artificial autonomous
intelligent creature that has no
biological limitations like we do in
terms of like its ability to absorb
radiation from space and we create one
of those little guys just like that
would an enormous head no sex organs
doesn't need sex organs you know and we
have this thing pilot these ships that
can defy our own physical limitations in
terms of what would happen to us if we
had to deal with you know 1 million
g-force because it's moving at some
preposterous rate through space like we
when we think of these things coming
from another planet if we think of life
on another planet if they can innovate
in a similar fashion the way we do we
would imagine they would create an
artificial creature to do all their
dirty work like why would they want to
like risk their body right yeah I mean
except I think creature might conjure up
stuff that I mean I okay his spaceship I
mean you don't have to have like build a
little thing that sits and turns the
steering wheel right I mean this could
be automated sure and you'd imagine a
technology that is spacefaring in a
serious way would have nanotechnology so
they have basically the ability to
arbitrarily configure matter in whatever
structure they wanted out of it like
nano scale right probes and things that
could shape-shift and it it would not be
that that would be this person sitting
in a seat behind the steering wheel like
it would just if they wanted to they
could be invisible to us I'll take like
nano scale things hiding in a rock
somewhere yes than just connecting with
an information
to some planetary sized computer
somewhere far away which would be doing
that so yeah I think that that's the way
that space is most likely to get
colonized it's not not going to be like
with meat sacks kind of driving
spaceships around and having Star Trek
adventures it's gonna be some spherical
frontier emanating from whatever the
home planet was moving at some
significant fraction of the speed of
light and converting everything in its
path into infrastructure of whatever
type is maximally valuable for that
civilization maybe computers and
launchers to launch more of these space
probes so that the whole wavefront can
continue to propagate but we are mean
one of the things you brought up earlier
that if human beings are going to
continue and we're going to propagate
through the universe we're going to try
to go to other places we're going we're
going to try to populate other planets
and are we going to do that with just
robots or we're gonna try to do that
biologically we're probably going to try
to do it biologically and one of the
things you were saying earlier is one of
the things that artificial intelligence
could possibly do has accelerate our
ability to travel to other lands or the
plants I mean we gonna try I mean in
fact some people are right trying to buy
what you I just think that's gonna not
lead to anything important until those
efforts becomes obsoleted by some
radical new technology wave probably
triggered by machine super intelligence
that then rapidly leads to something
approximating technological maturity
once once innovation happens at digital
timescales rather than human timescales
then all these things that you could
have met and we doing if I had 40,000
years to work on it we would have space
colonies and cures for aging and yeah
all of these things right but if that
thinking time happens you know digital
space then that long future gets
telescoped and I think you fairly
quickly reach a condition where you have
close to optimal technology and then you
can colonize the space cost-effectively
you just need to send out one little
prob that then can land on some resource
and set up a production facility to make
more problems and then it spreads
exponentially everywhere and then if you
want to you could then like after that
initial infrastructure has happened you
could transport biological human beings
in other planets if you want it it's not
really where the action is gonna be like
but but if we were concerned there's
some sort of a threat to the earth like
some sort of asteroid impact something I
mean that stuff technology averting some
asteroid would be I think trivial really
it would be like a gift of free energy
like oh here comes an energy package
great that's a funny way to look at it
do you think we're gonna eventually
colonize Mars well I think the the
answer is is this I think if and only if
we manage to get through these key
technological transitions and then I
think we will colonize not just Mars but
everything else that that is accessible
in the universe when you talk about
these things people always want to know
when well anything's gonna happen
what's the time yes a mom my guess would
be after technological maturity like
after a superintelligence now with Mars
it's possible that there would be like a
little kind of prototype colonization
thing because they're like people like
really excited about that so if yeah so
you could imagine some little demo
project happening sooner but if we're
talking about something say that would
survive long-term even if the earth
disappeared like some kind of
self-sustaining
yeah civilization I think that's gonna
be very difficult to do until you have
super intelligence and then it's gonna
be trivial so you think super
intelligence could potentially be what I
mean that one of the applications would
be to terraform Mars yeah change the
atmosphere to make it sustainable for
Biological life yeah the second spot
yeah for example a vacation yes now I
also think that at this this is this is
a very radical context technology called
maturity because we're already maybe
there are additional technologies we
can't even think of yet but even just
what we already know
about physics etc can sort of see
possible technologies that we don't yet
or they were not yet able to build but
we can see that they would be consistent
with physics that it would be stable
structures yeah
and already that creates a vast space of
things you could do and so for example I
think it would be possible at the
technological maturity to upload human
minds into two computers for example
yeah and so that you think that's gonna
happen like Ray Kurzweil stuff well I
think again it would be technically
possible at technical maturity to do it
mm-hmm
now whether it's actually going to
happen then depends a do we reach
technical maturity and we do with are we
interested in using our technology for
that purpose at that time but if both of
those seem kind of reasonably possible
yeah reasonably possible in most of all
and especially in comparison what we've
already achieved